así que sé bienvenido a tam tam
canada hoy con visitantes
especial un invitado misterioso vas
averiguar que es todo el mundo aquí en
estudio es que es así que no podemos
Jugando a los maceteros te extraño
hacer preguntas que responde con sí o
por no dura 30 minutos y despues de eso
nos vamos a casa no hoy
hoy el tema nos toca a todos
afectan a los medios no solo a la radio
canadá examinaremos el éxito y
peores éxitos de radio canada por
relación con esta realidad de la presencia
rostros que representan
diversidad canadiense ya sea en el
radio ya sea en televisión o
todavía en la web en facebook live en
youtube en el sitio web de rci net
actualmente estamos transmitiendo en
plataformas en vivo de tres vías
simultáneamente y decimos que youtube tiene un
segunda pista en facebook
felicidades y youtube entonces
hoy el tema que di yo
siempre da un titulo chistoso pero
muestra hoy tengo todo
no me hagas caso porque yo no
no puedo realmente y la historia
rostros de nuestra diversidad en el
Los medios canadienses estuvieron en el programa.
pero como tienes imaginacion
veces mucho mas que yo yo tu
estaba pidiendo encontrarme un sitio mejor
para este programa que habla de
diversidad de rostros alrededor de los treinta y
la radio empezaremos con nuestra
invitado misterioso fue en la misma dirección
stephen de las mascaras de la diversidad
porque tendemos a esconderlos
mucho
en fin que bonito que me encante esa paloma
puedes hacerlo mejor
radio canada te insta
bueno terminas en
Preguntas
bueno si eso es bueno marie-claude son
todos los que estamos en los medios somos
todos
y luego leonardo la historia es la
acentos asi que no se que es
nuestra nota aquí en el show side
diversidad, pero eso está bien de todos modos
muy bien gracias
un poco de sangre india que tenia
origenes del nombre yo como digo hecho
lo esencial viene a nueva francia ya
sma aquí le damos la bienvenida a luc sonor rade
que se especializa en publicar
lo que no es necesario porque es
su dirección de correo electrónico que aparece allí
seis enfermos
sí absolutamente tuve que distinguirme
de un otoño con sentarse vino del
nuevo baile figeac yo soy stéphane
42 puedo hacerte feliz
Estoy aquí antes de finalmente, así que es luc.
Simard usted es responsable de
políticas de diversidad en el aire
radio-canada ocupa buena parte
de tu dia si y yo yo tenia
otro sitio para ofrecer estas renuncias
no hay hombrecito mañana
blanco en el aire todo verde en
la antena de los hombres blancos como yo
pero no me hagas no lo somos
Todavía con los marcianos pero estamos haciendo
progreso en la diversidad
pero que cosas se podrian decir
cuantificar las cosas porque tenemos
la gente va al extranjero que se dice a sí misma
pero ¿por qué habla de diversidad en
la antena
con nosotros no hay problema y
canada link hay una gran presencia de
personas nacidas en el extranjero
montreal en canadá toronto finalmente nosotros
podra volver pero cuales son
las estadísticas que podrías
sal de tu caja de herramientas que nosotros
mostraría aquí la importancia del desafío que
nos espera
entonces sabes entonces ni siquiera lo sabes
vi lo último
en realidad si son los ultimos
dígitos las melodías y los dígitos de la
ultimo censo 2016 y vemos que
las minorías visibles están en
todo canadá estos 22 3% de los
población
así que digamos alrededor de una cuarta parte de la
población y cuando miramos a montreal
se trata de la misma proporción
obviamente la ciudad de montreal es
como Canadá en su conjunto y
así que aquí tenemos un montón de
dos jóvenes de minorías visibles si
mira tambien la inmigracion es
que hay tantos inmigrantes
Canadá es un país de inmigración por lo que
por el momento no tengo no tengo
exactamente los numeros de montreal
pero tal vez aquí solo seamos paloma que
yo tenia en esas aguas
pero en este caso sabemos que en montreal un
cada segunda persona tiene al menos un padre
nacido en el extranjero
así que eso es el cincuenta por ciento de la
Montreal población a la que pertenece
ya sea minorías visibles una minoría
audible o aún así 50% tantos
de los cuales tienen referentes culturales
entonces si vuelvo a las minorias
visible
obviamente podemos de minorías visibles
estudiantes de octavo grado en montreal
generación por lo que no hay enlace
directa entre el hecho de ser de
la inmigración es una minoría visible
hay que distinguir siempre entre los dos
un muy importante no es una molestia
cuando o cuando somos negros pero esa lente
es tenue aquí a finales del 18 al
principios del siglo XIX
y empieza a ser un buen momento
no escuches quien esta ahi no solo
porque es un equipo no es
miembro del equipo regular aquí está
todo un equipo pero no es verdad
ella hace muchas cosas cuando tu
hacer algo en el
día que sabemos que has pasado
allí pero en serio pertenecemos
también del equipo de luc simard sí yo
no trabajo mucho muy a menudo
con luc simard al final de la pregunta
investigación para enriquecer nuestra
directorio de diversidad de radio canada
porque tenemos un directorio en
que los periodistas pueden
uso para recoger personas
diversas fuentes de información
así que trabajo un poco para eso pero yo
yo tambien hago tambien doy capacitacion
a los periodistas que buscan
radio canada y luego nos encontramos lo suficiente
a menudo personas periodistas
de salimata
editor para hablar con ellos un
algunos de los objetivos que radio-canada que
se ocupa de la diversidad cultural
la diversidad es superada
radio-canada para explicar aquí de nuevo
una vez que los que están en el extranjero
no conozco bien radio-canada ni aqui
diversidad canadiense bicic
otoño representado en radio canada este
parte del mundo de esta corporación estatal
nosotros tampoco hicimos eso vamos a
hacer hablar hay dinero que sigue
con eso normalmente si no llenamos
los objetivos para los que fuimos
nacido pero diré más allá
de eso, stéphane, es que estamos hablando
una audiencia diversa que dicen es
cuando la sociedad canadiense
diversificado
entonces la gente espera que el publico
espera que representemos a sus
realidad por lo tanto la realidad en la que
los canadienses viven es una realidad
diversificado en el que las especies
expertos en todo en todo tipo de
campos y expertos para ser todos
orígenes mixtos
así que él espera eso de nosotros
nosotros los trabajadores los creadores
entonces sabes que este espectáculo es
construido
un poco como roma por encima de esto
hill dilo que solo espesamos para
videos aquí en lenguaje web
entonces te vamos a presentar esto
primer video íbamos a ver que pasa
pase a otro lado uno para criticar
mantenimiento de radio-canada quiénes son los demás
muy normal
así que aquí está el video 75 aniversario de
Video viral del año pasado en Montreal
[Música]
Nunca no
Paso toda mi vida es con nosotros
estas noticias jallet
[Música]
375 dispositivos
cada mes
luego el escultural de montreal pero
no es la cara multicultural de montreal
esta historia hace mucho ruido
especialmente en las redes sociales
que es por que tuviste
este patín es lo que sabemos que hay
sin minorías visibles
uno de cada cinco significa que está ausente paso
entre los niños al final hubo algunos
pero mira este hecho lo que me sorprendió
Cuanto más entiendo que el empalme
cultural como dices du de
montreal y posiblemente blanco murió
uno francés y otro inglés
pero los niños de montreal es
no es que así al final veamos un cierto
número de niños pero me pregunté
pregunta común que se les hace a qué
colegio al que fueron a recoger
este grupo no hay diversidad
es muy dificil tener versalles
Tuve que trabajar incluso si encuentras estos
jóvenes en defensa de los organizadores de la
375 de hecho rehicieron una versión
después de eso porque estaban amargamente
¿En qué están estos mismos habitantes de Montreal?
cuatro
chi chi y 2000 fueron apuntados para que
simplemente no tenía ningún sentido común
eso es lo que tienen tan bien
trabajado que borraron todos los rastros
de este video solo hay uno
lugar en un regreso de canada
internacional marie claude usted
entender sin esta cara tan cultural
pero sin multi drop y es
al final no es representativo
es falta de sensibilidad eso seguro
ver que no era una prioridad
no era un objetivo que tenían
haciendo el video de defensa otra vez
organizarme porque creo que
es una realidad
los vemos aquí en radio-canada también nosotros
a nuestras redes de contacto nuestras redes
los profesionales a menudo se parecen a nosotros
y luego en radio canada no los tengo
dígitos a nivel de trabajo en radio
Canadá, pero solicite que me pregunte su
que los ecos
esos numeros pero eso es lo que yo
saber es que radio recursos
Canadiense donde las redes de medios
Québec en general es
recursos no me gusta decirlo
término sobresalto belin o la red
francófono pero y tengo la impresión
todavía kaka que carece de diversidad
por todos estos recientes que saben
puede ir a la escuela primaria a buscar
los orígenes de por qué
el invernadero una tierra dice no a estos
da vueltas ahi pero yo creo que hay de todo
que las redes son muy homogéneas
este fenómeno de la sociedad creo que
que el reverso de este hecho derecho a la
c1
es un retrato de hecho de lo que venimos
a ver si el retrato de la industria
Cultura quebequesa de comidas desde el
sociedad y en la industria de Quebec
de la cultura e incluyo los medios de comunicación y
Incluso incluyo radio Canadá allí
porque básicamente todo lo que
hecho de que son productos culturales y
Incluso puse la información en el
productos culturales
pero se amplían para mirar el
teatro cuando miramos el conjunto de
variedades de televisión
dramático vemos hasta qué punto el cine y
incluso tomamos la música
artes visuales, etc. eso es todo
mucho de eso y mucha gente que
me gustaría entrar en esta industria
pero que se enfrentan a todo tipo
obstáculos
así que dices eso es así es como es
a ver comenzo en radio-canada
ahora tan grande revelación
esto va a levantar las cejas de mucha gente
tener mucha gente aquí tienes
Explícanos podemos casin por no
extraño los números esto es lo que
Los usuarios de Internet te están viendo actualmente
describirles esta primera serie de páginas
de los datos que ha recopilado sí
por lo que es interesante sirve es du
canadá tenemos un gran sistema de archivo
de nuestras emisiones lo que nos permite
saber exactamente qué ponerse
la antena
incluyendo por lo tanto el tipo de evitar que
invitamos a nuestros programas para que
aquí estamos hablando de programas de televisión
hablando de programas de noticias
puede retroceder un poco
poco así que aquí están las emisiones y
aqui vemos la radio asi los numeros
parecerse es alrededor del 3% de
minorías visibles
un poco más en TV 3.5 y un poco
menos en la radio por lo que es obviamente
siempre el músico para identificar el
minorías visibles en la radio pero por lo demás
pero ves es asi si miramos
que ahorita deciamos mas o menos
una cuarta parte por lo tanto 23% minorías más precisas
visible en montreal y en nuestro
transmisiones de radio o televisión
aproximadamente el 3% para que podamos ver
aunque estemos no estamos al nivel
que deberíamos estar ahí siempre hay
obviamente razones que pueden explicar
cual es el nivel que nos dan
deberíamos ser idealmente
debe estar a nivel de la población
deberíamos tener en nuestra antena
guardar el fiel reflejo de la sociedad
Montrealer si solo tomo el
Compañía de Montreal y me disculpo por
todas las personas que nos escuchan y
me imagino que es la gran mayoria
que están fuera de montreal pero allí
solo tienes que saber que yo
piensa en todos los que somos
escuchar sabe que la gran mayoría
reedita nuestras entrevistas terminadas
aquí desde montreal los próximos días
sobre temas de Montreal, pero es
invitado aquí debajo, por eso
por lo tanto, es importante poder
elevarnos a un nivel que se asemeje
el de la población añadirá un poco
de la visión canadiense
vamos a salir un poco de montreal
Quebec hablaremos de números que
ya he tomado algunas dosis
información que le permitiría
para tener la respuesta a esto primero
pregunta del primer día base y
ustedes hogares en el primer juego de
el dia que me acuerdo que esta primero
juego hay tres en el show este
primer juego por valor del 20% hasta
final el tendra todas las respuestas
aquí, de los 36 millones de canadienses en
cuantos millones nacieron en
extranjero
y cuantos millones eran uno
minoría visible ambas canciones pop
después de prácticamente comparable buscado
no ya contestado no no no quiero
que ella luego no dijo nada leonardo ok ellos
5 millones 5 millones 7 millones 7
millones no sé 8 millones 8.7
millones ambas la respuesta correcta
concreto para su lanzamiento realmente en el
buena zona como dicen te queria
hablar un poco aquí sobre para siempre
del proyecto de radio canada para mejorar la
anotar porque es lo ideal, pero sabemos
que no va muy bien
que hacemos entonces sabemos que
ponte no solo tu quieres
cambia las cosas por dentro
radio canada a través del diálogo
reuniones en diez años se une en dar
herramientas
hablamos de ello un poco antes, pero también
tratamos de convencer, por ejemplo, pero
diciendo si quieres hacer negocios
con radio canada tal vez tu
también deberías considerar seriamente
en la industria tener esta noción de
de justicia en relación con la multiplicidad
cultura de nuestra sociedad
hay un proyecto en particular en este momento
ven pero mas que un proyecto pues un
obligación quien y quien ahora hace
desde diciembre por lo que es
muy reciente desde el mes pasado en
todos los productores independientes que
quiero presentar los programas de radio
canadá entonces es importante
distinguir lo que vimos hace un momento
en la televisión eran programas
selección de información realizada
resultados totalmente a largo plazo de
la parte del personal de radio canada dice
luc queremos agregar un video para
apoya tus palabras lo miras y
verás que estás a tu nombre
tu nos escribiras que pasa
es algo que la gente
afuera podrán ver a las personas que
quiere hacer negocios con nosotros usted
reconozca entonces sí lo hago entonces
como te gustaria un proyecto entonces que eso
por lo tanto se aplica a todas las personas que quieren
están embarcados en un proyecto para emitir
variedades un proyecto documental donde un
proyecto de serie radiofónica
canadá así que vamos rápido aquí pero
eres muy fácil de encontrar en el sitio
radio canada internet
y ves que acabamos de ver dos
tipos de documentos que se adjuntan
entonces estos documentos allí es simplemente
primero un documento que explica
¿Por qué queremos hacer esto y
básicamente nos recuerda
la importancia de reflejar a la población
y el otro documento baja este
formulario allí se ve en este
momento es decir, un plan de inclusión
diversidad que ahora requiere
ella productores independientes y
no olvidemos una vez más la inmensa
mayoría de los espectáculos que las personas que
escúchanos ver televisión
serie de programas de variedades
dramático
es la gran mayoría de la visión y
todos estos espectáculos están hechos por
productores independientes
así que desde diciembre el productor
independiente debe presentar un plan
diversidad inclusión que define
lo que quiere poner a los casos y lo que
tipo de contenido que bueno
dijon quiz sobre qué tema
los temas de stéphane u otros tipos
de temas que van a animar es lo que
será sí, un animador jouinot fue atacado
en este caso no muy visible en este
caso es lo que el tema
tocará
tema de la diversidad cultural que es
la audiencia en 21 / obviamente cada
espectáculo de historia de los años veinte
máximo es lo que en los papeles
los principales son el talento en serie
dramático por ejemplo los cráneos de
se darán los papeles principales a
actrices y comediantes de minorías
visible porque el anfitrión del juego
cuestionario sobre un anfitrión dos
cualquier minoría y otros
personalidades tus invitados en el aire
así que todo eso estará incluido a partir de ahora
ya celebrar ya es una obligacion
mas productores y parece que nada
pero es un gran paso adelante para
radio canada porque anteriormente
tenía tres líneas que decían hacer el
mejores esfuerzos posibles para
reflejan la diversidad de la población
de ahora en adelante hay unas bellas formas
no son muy complicados pero hay que
devanarse los sesos encontrar algo
Lo que sé es que nuestro enfoque es
la zanahoria pero sin palo lo se
es inevitable ahora
ya no es posible presentar un proyecto
emisión incluso para los detectores de
metal y vuelve después de decir
observar crisis en 2018 no es
no eres verdad no lo eres
en el precio de la promesa es lo que
vas a hacer esto con mis colegas
obviamente de la tensión responsable de la
variedades de la nación que deben
aplica esto entonces
y confío en ellos completamente
para replicar eso creo que ya veremos
resultados cuando en el drama se necesita
tres años desarrolló una serie que vamos a
para poder ver en el aire no vamos a ver el
resultado de mis mañanas en variedad estoy bien
un poco mas rapido pero esta bien
incluso toma un tiempo
desarrollar conceptos y filmar
episodios lo veremos estoy convencido
que lo vamos a ver
y como medirlo bien no se si
quieres que te hable
salir de radio canada
renuncié a radio canada porque el
productores independientes con los que
¿productor de programas de negocios?
cuarta parte de estos costos de emisión de
variedades
a menudo son los mismos productores
con quien con cuando quiera con
que los canales especializados de
bellefon para hacerlo tenemos un acercamiento
que está a nivel de la industria
así que yo lo que quiero y lo que yo
buscar
tenemos un grupo de trabajo que proporcionamos
ayer ya mas de tres años es
para llegar a los criterios de la industria
es que toda la industria está progresando
estación de radio canadiense
no se si los demas poco hacen
casi lo mismo o algo
género
así que entramos para ir en este
dirección allí porque estamos en el proceso de
concebir ahora mismo con un
universidad el eco de los estudios superiores
comercial de montreal hec montreal
como se llaman como el prefiere
se llamó diseñamos una herramienta de medición
que va a ser una herramienta de medición para
la industria no solo para radio canada
porque a la larga nos vimos
justo ahora somos capaces de medir es
bastante bien lo que hacemos pero se tarda
una herramienta para toda la industria
es una herramienta aceptada por todos
industria
por lo que se está convirtiendo en
este momento y no hay radio solo
Canadá que están pagando para desarrollar este
herramienta allí nuestros costos nuestros colegas de tv
up también es productor y director de
emitir
es hora de traer el
publico publico en general
acuerdo en nuestros debates no es
porque estamos en la web a través de eso
que el publico en general no es quien
importado
así que aquí está la pregunta la pregunta tam
tam esta semana y yo estaba preguntando
marie claude el
aquí está la pregunta que aparecerá
a los pocos segundos de la pregunta
misterio para mi es la manera nada y
aquí está ella allí los medios alrededor
usted web radio televisión refleja
la importancia de la sociedad
multicultural que te tendría ella que
vosotras